Scientists have known for years that liquid water existed on Mars in its ancient
past and it's even been observed but exist in its liquid form in the modern day
from your hours on the surface of Mars.
But soon NASA may announced and his spent large amounts of liquid water that
exists seasonally and marched for longer,
but still short periods of time.
Many have often speculated that this is the case.
Maurice has a large amount of water only.
It's mostly frozen.
We're scientists had just discovered that this is not always the case.
The Mars reconnaissance orbiter,
according to the team as discover that seasonal dark streets appearing on the
surface of Mars can be attributed to surface water appearing periodically and
Marge is warm season until it eventually is lost to the atmosphere or this
reason.
Many suspects that the report will evolve around liquid water on Mars and are
anxiously awaiting.
The reason,
of course,
that's just so exciting is that on earth water,
organic molecules and an energy source equals life.
Many believe that in a similar environment,
the same is true across the university and many believe Mars would be the first
candidate for exploring these hypotheses,
especially if liquid water does exist there.
As we hope the team will announce tomorrow if this discovery does eventually
lead to life,
and if the life can be proven to have not originated from Earth billions of
years ago and have been transported there,
it will fundamentally change all of science in human thing.
This discovery may indeed for shadow the discovery of alien life,
and that discovery may lead to a finding of life across the solar system on
Europa and sell it as titan and many other worlds and eventually across the
entire universe.
Many questions would of course be brought up such as where does all this water
originates?
However,
tomorrow at 1130 eastern standard time,
these questions and much more hopefully be explained by Nassis team
to follow updates on these amazing,
this federal reason for more videos in playlists on astrobiology astronomy,
science in general,
and many other topics,
I invite you to check out fire.
Thank you for watching.